Billy Gardell our longtime friend the
comedian stand-up comic and Mike and
Molly Fame as well and so much more back
here under Rich Eisen sure how you been
Billy a man first-time caller longtime
listener what's going on body a my take
on paint me a word picture what's your
date what's your day like today give it
to me why I got suited up at about 10
a.m. because I got a roam around the
city today and I've got a fit make a few
of my favorite local food stops and
lunch stops and coffee stop sit back I'm
sitting down time and a beautiful Market
Square it's lit up getting ready for the
holidays I'm at the Nicholas coffee
which has been around for about 98 years
if it makes a great coffee from wait
before Starbucks started burning it and
charging seven bucks a copy so I'm just
down here amongst my people getting
ready for the game it should be a nice
40 39 degree 40 degree game just enough
to make the southerners a little
uncomfortable which is what we like to
do and lots going on in this game you
know I can't take this team lightly we
got to really get up for them and I
think the city knows that we know our
ball tears you know because it's a lot
going on just not on the field with you
know Tennessee's you know magic trick
offense and their tough defense but even
on the sidelines is going to be a uh
this is a very big battle because you
got malarkey coming in here you see our
offensive coordinator but more
importantly the legendary Hall of Famer
Dick LeBeau coming back to town so you
know he wants to beat us and you know
our nudie guy wants to beat him to make
a mark respectfully but I think this is
this is this is a big game for us we got
five of the last seven at home and this
one and the Patriots are the two biggest
that are that are going to come down the
pike I think for the rest of the season
so it's playoff fever tonight is what it
feels like I agree with you Billy you
know how did how did that slip through
the cracks here of us talking about this
game that Dick LeBeau is back in the
house I think we retired psycho no but
you're right though you're right yeah
how many hot by the way how many revenge
minded 80 year olds do you know I was
probably doing push-ups
right now it's probably somewhere in a
hotel just hanging from a bar going set
ups crunches I mean you know that was a
hard decision for this city because he's
beloved and and of course a Hall of
Famer and his players remember his Hall
of Fame speech all his players showed up
at his Detroit number yes and and he's
just revered here and you know that's
newer said then they get decision to
move on to the next level and you know
we I don't think anybody is thinking
well here comes LuPone in November and
this game could have some implications
just we need to keep pace with Tom Brady
and the Patriots and working that you
know we were better at getting up for
the big game we have trouble if you're a
Pittsburgh ER you know this this curse
you know we're you could be the toughest
team in the league it will be like yeah
let's go come on right now
let's play you know but if it's
Indianapolis you know we're barely gonna
get out of there with a field goal so we
take care of business as well as we
showed with the cheese we should Billy
Gardell here on the Rich Eisen show and
it's interesting Billy the Titans play
football the way the Steelers used to
they really they're you know they come
in here they run downhill and they want
to hit you in the mouth and it's not
just the first back it's second back -
and it could be the matter back on
occasion here yeah everybody's hitting
everybody tonight and it's gonna be cold
there's gonna be a lot of snot bubbles
tonight a lot of snot bubbles you know
and also to man the Titans used to be in
the AFC Central right with you guys that
used to bowl yeah Houston you used to be
Houston by useful way to oral Earl
Campbell Oilers we used to get bump
Phillips an aneurysm every year but
before the AFC South in a way began I
mean Eddie George used to become there
you study those Eddie George and Ray vs
Ravens and Eddie George versus Steelers
and then you know those those Greg Lloyd
you know or talk well I mean we're going
back to this is the this has got some
history this matchup that I think we're
gonna probably mine on our pregame show
tonight yeah you know everybody likes to
knock the Thursday game I'm not the
biggest fan because I think it's really
hard on the players but you know
everybody likes to knock the marquee
lineups for Thursday night's game but I
tuned in for this
well I think this one's going to be well
worth your time I love it now is it true
you went to the Penguins game last night
as it depends Tuesday night I'm making
around rich because I'm seeing time to
do a benefit for the Pittsburgh Ballet
for the children's theater on Saturday
and I'm performing at the Sands Casino
in Bethlehem on Saturday and my wife
said since you did a good deed you can
stay I'm gonna go to both sporting
events you gotta give to get man you got
a gift to get Billie so and so I guess
walked me through what this town is
going through right now with
back-to-back cups Steelers 702 I think
we got a little bit of I think we got a
little bit of a Stanley Cup hangover on
this second Cup because we're what are
we ten and seven now and Sydney scored
his first goal to win it and over time
Tuesday night because I was there that's
what I like to do but that's the first
goal we've had in about six games so I
think there's a little bit of fog going
on from back-to-back drops but
Sullivan's a great coach and he'll have
them pull together and my favorite guy
to watch is his name is Shari but
everybody in Pittsburgh just calls up
Shari hey you like that Shari I like him
a lot so he's my favorite guy right now
and and I think they'll pull it together
and we'll get very serious about hockey
right around Christmas time we check in
on the Pens
you know and tell them but right around
Christmas time won't get very serious
about hockey but right now it's all
about Steelers and marching towards home
field because I cannot I cannot go see
Brady in Foxborough I can't I just can't
do it we need to get them here to have a
really good shot at beating them and I
think that I'd love to get that by week
but more importantly I'd like to stay on
pace with them and and then face them in
December for a game that really needs
something but that all starts with
tonight rich we got all of us on tonight
before I let you go Billy I got Marv
Albert calling in we're in Myron copes
radio booth right now where's Roy
I swam a big night
I know mad just went who's smiling coke
I know I know
burgers went that's right all right mine
with my own coke the legendary the
legendary voice of the Pittsburgh
Steelers through the hard times and then
through the Super Bowls and then also
the inventor of the Terrible Towel and
this is what a lot of extremes don't
understand all the money that was given
as my release a the Terrible Towel
possesses mighty powers on offense your
offense alike but all the money from
that pal goes to the Children's Hospital
so that's why when one of these players
coming from a foreign team and they
disrespect that palate I end up with an
injury it's worth Illingworth it's a way
worse curse in the front and a madman
cover well put Billy thanks for calling
in brother I hope to see you here
tonight okay
man I love you to be safe god bless you
for staying loyal to your jets it shows
a lot of character and and if I don't
get to talk to you man Happy
Thanksgiving right back to you that's
Billy Gardell there's Billy Gardell big
Steeler fan actor comedian loved him in
my komali now he's all fired up for his
Steelers tonight the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience